привіт
іноземець
[Оплески]
о крихітко
розмовляйте українською без одягу мої
дорогі друзі голова
прем'єр-міністр
мідь
так
честь голови
Лаура Ешлі
Шановні президенти
прем'єр-міністри
віце-президент
будь лідером
політична партія влади та сім'ї
це дуже важливо
для мене
і я хочу подякувати вам за цю
дуже важливу нагороду
не лише для мене, не лише для моєї
політичної партії,
я вважаю цю нагороду за той розум
Збройні сили
[Оплески],
щоб
зупинити другу за величиною армію у світі
з ядерною зброєю
біля імперіалістичного
диктатора
та  Російські люди, які прийшли вбивати
українців зараз і роблять це протягом 10
місяців без будь-яких пояснень, як
це може допомогти,
і
українські люди
без тепла вдома,
але з великим ударом у серцях
[Оплески]
без води, меду,
але з першим
у будь-якому прибув  з нашої душі
нема електрики,
але буде велика сила, щоб перемогти
хвилю цього світу
і це не тільки війна між
Україною та Руссю  серед іншого,
це війна
за весь вільний світ,
це більше за свободу,
це війна за демократію,
це війна за нашу радість, вільне і
демократичне майбутнє
та українська Україна
роблять велику роботу